les portes restent fermées mais sur
scène les berrichons mesure calcul grand
max le constat est net
il faut penser la programmation
autrement pour ceux déconfinement
annonce les bains douches notre façon de
notre façon de faire notre façon de voir
les choses
c'était la proximité public artist est
là du coup avec le co lead
voilà vous allez avoir une salle on va
faire sortir les gens
ça va être très compliqué d'ouvrir un
bar ça va être très compliqué que les
gens se retrouvent pour discuter
ça va être très compliqué d'échanger
avec artistes parce que on n'a pas les
surfaces nécessaires
on n'a pas des énormes sur place pour
pouvoir pallier à toutes les mesures
sanitaires difficile de maintenir les
mesures barrières de distanciation ce
qui va être compliqué pour les bains
douches
c'est plutôt les grands les spectacles à
quatre cinq six personnes sur scène
parce que d'après ce qu'on peut lire
actuellement on va pas pouvoir mettre
plus de deux personnes sur notre plateau
si on respecte les les hypothèses de
travail qui est qui sont donnés
actuellement par le kiff huit
actuellement du gouvernement
la salle devient elle aussi un problème
car il faut diminuer la jauge de 209
spectateurs de cette petite salle rural
on travaille plutôt sur une hypothèse de
baisse de la jauge de réduction de la
jauge des des salles comme les bains
douches et on va passer à 60 70 places
maximum
alors qu'on à 209 fauteuil les
professionnels attendent des
clarifications du ministère de la
culture avant fin juin pour réaliser
leur programmation de fin d'année